midterm elections are coming up but does
your vote actually make a difference you
as voter turnout is amongst the lowest
in the entire developed world and it
might be because we feel like our
individual vote won't make a difference
in the mass of votes like one skittle
won't make a difference in a jar of
hundreds but it's time we stop horsing
around and we get to voting because
democracy it's like pretty important you
might think one vote will make a
difference but if you and the person
next to you feel the same way then that
creates a domino effect that could lead
to the loss of a bunch of votes Plus
who's as a few votes can make a
difference check this out
in 2000 George W Bush won't Florida by
only 537 votes about 6 million votes
were cast in Florida which means that he
won by only 0.009 percent and this gave
him the presidency in 1839 Marcus Morden
became the governor of Massachusetts
thanks to warm above so like out of this
pool of ducks does one dude
made history I know it feels like our
votes are microscopic but so was that
bacteria that caused a black plague and
that killed about 25 million people so
small things can have a big impact in
1994 two candidates from Wyoming State
House received the exact same number of
votes
Ron Duluth II won the seat when his name
written on a ping-pong ball was drawn
from a cowboy hat and again in 2011
Tonya Flanagan and Linda Mason Hamer
type during a primary election in North
Las Vegas Mison hammered through the
higher card securing her a spot in the
general election which she went out to
lose what that's not the point another
example comes from 2008 when Democrat Al
Franken beat Republican Norm Coleman by
312 votes out of almost 2.9 million
votes cast 312 votes is about 0.0
11.43848 M and his boyfriend Steve so
regardless of what party you are voting
for you should get to voting
[Music]